i used to say uh 10 years ago that this
world was optional
that if you don't like it just turn it
off it's okay no problem you can't take
a break from it anymore it's become the
way you educate the way you entertain
the way you make money right the way you
communicate the way you have a social
life so we're going to have to adapt
these platforms to these human
regulations i used to think it's fine to
have all that bad stuff online because
people can just turn it off but they
can't now
our guest is credited for scaling google
into the 21st century taking the company
from its silicon valley startup route to
a global tech leader
eric schmidt was google ceo for 10 years
2001 to 2011. during that time the
company launched google maps gmail
google chrome and bought youtube just to
name a few of its many milestones after
serving as ceo he became executive
chairman and then technical advisor for
alphabet inc google's parent company
totaling 19 years at google not to
mention nearly 20 years prior leading
other tech and software-based companies
in 2020 eric left google for new
ventures notably contributing one
billion dollars through his
philanthropic organization to fund
talented people offering science and
technological innovations to the world's
largest and hardest problems he also
co-authored a book this year alongside
henry kissinger and dan huttenlocker the
age of ai and our human future the three
of them used their diverse careers eric
writing from his entrepreneurship and
technology business expertise to inform
on the current state of artificial
intelligence and to raise essential
questions for a world fully integrated
with ai
eric gives me his thoughts on our not
too distant future plus we discuss mark
zuckerberg's transforming facebook into
the metaverse whether google is a
monopoly limiting all others in its
market and whether big tech is censoring
what they consider misinformation
[Music]
hey and welcome this is the ben shapiro
show sunday special this show is
sponsored by expressvpn don't like big
tech and the government spying on you
visit expressvpn.com
ben just a reminder we will be doing
some bonus questions at the end with
eric schmidt the only way to get access
to that part of the conversation is to
become a member we're going to go deep
at the end on the impacts of ai on human
reason how it's going to redefine what
it means to be a human you're not going
to want to miss it head on over to
dailywire.com become a member you'll
have the full conversation eric thanks
so much for joining the show
thank you ben i wanted to be on for a
long time i really appreciate that and
hope you survive whatever blowback comes
your way to us having an open
conversation uh so why don't we start
with the topic of your brand new book
which is uh artificial intelligence so
you know for a lot of folks who are not
versed in this including me when i hear
artificial intelligence i tend to think
of you know the iron giant uh or gizmo
basically robots that talk back to you
but obviously ai is is much more
sophisticated and all-encompassing than
that i think people are not fully aware
of what ai means for the future of
humanity so why don't we start by
defining what a.i is
well first thank you for this and it's
exactly the right starting question
most of your audience when they think of
ai they think of the following they
think of a
man who creates a killer robot
the killer robot escapes and the female
scientist somehow slays the robot
and that is precisely not what we're
talking about here
that's great fiction and it's a great
movie but it's not going to happen that
way
what's really going to happen is that
our world will be surrounded by digital
intelligences
and these intelligences are partially
like humans
and they'll make things more efficient
they'll make new discoveries they'll be
around
they'll help educate our children
they'll discover new things we can talk
to them they'll provide companionship
um they'll also change the way we think
about war
and our own identity we wrote the book
to explore those questions
so
first question that sort of comes to
mind immediately for me here is whether
human beings are ready for this so brett
weinstein and heather heing uh wrote a
book recently where they talked about
the fact that so much of the stuff that
we interact with even now
is is well beyond the capacity of sort
of our evolutionary adaptability that if
you look back to sort of the lizard
brains we developed in the savannahs and
jungles hundreds of thousands of years
ago and we were trying to survive that
we are now using devices and we really
don't know the impact of those devices
on on how we think obviously the the
sort of stuff that comes to mind for a
lot of folks is the use of social media
the the the addictiveness for example of
social media
are human beings going to be able to
adapt to a world that is filled with all
of these all these things that human
beings were not privy to in the natural
environment
it's going to be really stressful and we
need to have a whole new philosophy
about how we're going to deal with
what this does to humanity
it's interesting that 400 years ago we
went through something which is a
transition
from the age of faith where people
believe that god told them what to do
to what is called the age of reason
where you could have critical thinking
and you could look at a situation and
you could say is that good for society
or good for me or a moral judgment and
so forth
and this age of reason spawned the
industrial age everything we see around
us before that we were very very
primitive it was called the dark ages
so we believe in why we wrote the book
is that we're going to go into a new
epoch of human experience because humans
are not used to having a human-like
assistant
partner
opponent and so forth in their world
if you look at what happened with with
social media
people like myself who helped build
these systems had no idea
that they would be used by for example
the russians to change try to change our
elections or the addictive behavior
would drive people crazy with special
interest groups especially full of
falsehoods
we didn't know
that this would have happened would we
have if we knew known it would we have
done it i don't know
but this time these tools are much more
powerful they're much more capable of
for example driving you crazy making you
addicted and also educating you and
making you more powerful we want to have
a philosophical discussion about what
we're doing to humans with this
technology so in a second i want to get
back to sort of the political impact of
of technology that you sort of mentioned
there um but but i want to talk to you
about you know what exactly these
technologies are going to look like on a
more practical level so you talk about
them teaching your kids or you talk
about them them educating you creating
new innovations how fast are we going to
get to this sort of pseudo very
sophisticated ai because right now one
of the limitations on ai is that it
doesn't seem to be capable of the sort
of mass innovation that human minds are
capable of at this point but you're
talking about essentially machines being
able to create new machines which is a
different sort of thing how's humanity
going to deal with that and what does
that mean for the future of say work and
job creation
again incredibly good question
and
we don't really know there is a dispute
even among the authors on how quickly
this stuff will happen
i would say
15 years others would say 25 years does
it really matter
there's so much investment in this space
that i can tell you that it's going to
happen in some form and it'll happen
more quickly than we think and we're not
prepared for it and when i say we're not
prepared for it we're not prepared for
the new companies the impact on the
development of children how do you raise
a child where the child's best friend is
not human what happens uh example you
have a bear and you give the kid a bear
and every year you give the kid a
smarter bear and at 12 the bear is the
kid's best friend and the bear is
watching television and the bear says to
the kid i don't like this tv show and
the kid says i don't either
is that okay
that's a really significant change in
human existence which is being built now
in various forms do we really want to
put our kids through that i'm not sure
but i want to have the debate about it
i'll give you another example let's
think about war and conflict one of the
characteristics of war
is everything is occurring faster so
what happens when the ai system which
remember is not perfect it makes
mistakes
says you've got 24 seconds to press this
button before you're dead
you can't see the missile but i can do
you really think a human's not going to
press that button i don't think we know
how to deal with the compression of time
this intelligence and the characteristic
of this intelligence is it's dynamic
it's emergent
right it's imprecise so it makes
mistakes and it's learning
we've never had
a technology partner a platform an
object a machine that was like that
so one of the things that's been in the
media a lot lately is obviously
facebook's change over to meta uh
zuckerberg is now talking about the
metaverse and sort of your in you're now
living in in a different reality and
this is as i say
wide difference from the sort of way
that we have lived for all of human
history which was whatever our
aspirations whatever our sense of
identity they were bounded by the
reality around us right you could think
that you were the strongest guy in the
room and that lasted precisely as long
as you didn't run into the guy who's
stronger than you you might think that
you were invulnerable precisely up until
the time you fell off a cliff and hit a
rock at the bottom but in a virtual
reality space in a place where you're
never forced to actually confront other
human beings in a real human way when
you can create yourself and you can when
you can self-create your own identity it
seems like kind of a recipe for
in some ways the end of humanity as as
we know it and that's not meant you know
in terms of mass death but but
certainly in terms of what we think our
limitations are and i i think that
actually could breed some pretty bad
things not just not just you know a
feeling of freedom
you know the metaverse has been being
worked on for almost 30 years and the
basic idea here is that you put ar or
virtual reality headsets on and you live
in a virtual world where you're more
handsome you're more beautiful you're
more powerful you're richer you have a
comfy life it sounds great doesn't it
wouldn't you prefer to be in that life
than the reality of your life where you
have to struggle and where the commute
is terrible and people are yelling you
and so forth wouldn't it be wonderful to
be in such a virtual reality
i'm not sure
i'm worried that people will decide that
this virtual reality is so addictive
it's so fun to be that
fake person than who you really are that
people will cross over they'll get up in
the morning they'll do whatever they
have to do and then they put the
headsets on and they'll just sit there
for hours and hours and hours that's not
a great future for humanity
eric in just a second i want to ask you
about that future for humanity and what
it looks like in terms of separating
people into two groups we've talked a
lot about income inequality in in the
recent past but i'm wondering if we're
now going to get to
a true sort of human inequality that is
very bad for the future of civilization
via these sorts of devices in one second
first let's talk about life insurance
what's easier than opening a can of
cranberry sauce getting free life
insurance quotes with policy genius if
someone relies on your financial support
whether it's a child an aging parent
even a business partner you do need life
insurance it's just a thing that you
need i mean let's say for example that
you have been
given the gift of being able to create
ice from your fingers but suddenly you
lose control of that gift and you put an
entire city under the threat of complete
extinction thanks to an endless winter
you might think to yourself man they're
going to be mad should have gotten life
insurance policy genius makes it easy to
compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place why compare
well you could say 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius you could save 1300 or
more per year on life insurance by using
policy genius to compare policies the
licensed experts of policy genius work
for you not the insurance companies so
you can trust them to help you navigate
every step of the shopping and buying
process that kind of service has earned
policy genius thousands of five-star
reviews across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forbes advisor higher than options from
ladder ethos and bestow getting started
is simple first head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price when you're ready to apply the
policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and the scheduling for free
policy genius does not add on extra fees
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
right now get started policy genius when
it comes to insurance it's nice to get
it right
so eric you were talking about you know
whether people are just going to plug
into virtual reality and just live there
and it does remind me of a thought
experiment that the philosopher robert
nazek once posited the experience
machine and he specifically said that if
you gave people a choice whether they
could plug into essentially this right
they could plug into a world in which
all risk was debated you were going to
live a very happy life you're going to
get all the same emotional responses you
would in real life would you plug in and
he posited that for a lot of people the
answer would be no because you want to
have a real impact on the world i wonder
if you think that humanity is going to
break down into two groups people who
say yes to the experience machine and
people who say no to the experience
machine and frankly whether virtual
reality which is not in fact reality
reality is going to innervate our
civilization so entirely that people who
don't plug in people who are less
technologically adept people who care
less about the digital world actually
end up inheriting the earth while the
the most you know
sophisticated players in the space are
are distracted online essentially
you know a lot of people in literature
have talked about this and they've
talked about a drug called soma for
example
which uh in literature would sort of
take all your cares away
i'm not sure humans do very well in a in
a careless world where they don't have
the mission and meaning
it's also possible that the inverse of
what we just said is going to occur they
were going to get into this virtual
reality that seems so incredibly sexy
and they were gonna have all the same
behaviors we're gonna have greed and
envy and bad behavior
and
all the things that we don't like about
the physical world so it's
one of the things that we assumed when
we built all of this that we're now
dealing with was that connecting
everyone would be a great thing
and i'm very proud of the fact that i
worked really hard to connect everyone
in the world
so don't be shocked that they actually
talk to each other and that they say
things to each other that you don't
agree with
right it was noble to connect the world
and then we discover we don't like some
of the things they're talking about
that's crazy
so why don't we figure out a way to keep
everybody connected but also grounded in
physical reality but also keep them safe
right from stalking and trolling in some
of the worst kind of behaviors imagine
if you're trolled in physical life but
then you go to the virtual world you get
trolled there too
how depressing another possibility which
we talk about in the book
is that this
network of ai
system control
right which ultimately affects traffic
and the way you get pharmaceuticals and
the way you deal pay your taxes and the
way you are learning is so overwhelming
that will people will become nativist or
naturalist and they'll say i'm revolting
against the robot overlords it's not a
robot it's a computer but i'm revolting
against this digital world and the
control that it has over me that i
believe in my own individual freedom and
the only way i can do that is to turn it
off
and my guess is that 10 or 20 of the
people will ultimately say
turn this thing off
so yeah eric this does raise a question
that andrew yang has raised with regard
to artificial intelligence we talked to
him before his uh his run for for mayor
of new york and he was running for
president at the time talking about
universal basic income the idea being
that ai was going to become so
sophisticated that it took over a lot of
the fields that we don't tend to think
of as ai driven so typically job loss
due to technology in particular
industries has been relegated toward the
lower end of the income spectrum it's
been you know in manufacturing gigs or
it's been in self-checkout counters at
the at the local walmart but it hasn't
been in the so-called creative fields
and as ai gets more sophisticated and as
it moves up on the food chain in terms
of what kind of jobs it can replace
are we looking at the possibility of
mass unemployment and if so what is the
solution to that redistributionism may
not be enough because it turns out that
people kind of like working they need
something to do and the sort of fantasy
that people are then going to spend
their off hours painting especially if
the ais can paint better than we can you
could be looking at a total loss of
human meaning here
you said that so well
um
can i argue with your premise for a
second sure let's just use some data
i spent the last 10 years listening to
people telling me that the most dane
most endangered job in the world is
truck driving the truck driving will be
replaced by robots by computers
self-driving trucks will take over
what's the number one shortage in terms
of people in terms of people we can put
in jobs in america today truck driving
so i think there's something wrong with
this basic argument and i think what
happens is that yes the some of these
jobs will go away
but that because they're going away
because the markets are getting more
efficient i'm a capitalist capitalism
makes market more efficient more
efficient markets produce different jobs
in a larger space
so if you start from the premise that
our goal is to have economic growth
which benefits everyone the rich people
the poor people everyone the answer to a
lot of the problems in the world is a
job
right so we want to create as many jobs
as we can
now if we go back to your argument that
ai will displace jobs well so far we've
just been through this horrific pandemic
and we're trying to turn the economy
back on and we can't find enough people
who want to work
right that's a different problem then we
don't have jobs for them we have the
jobs for them but maybe they're not in
the right place or they're not skilled
or not motivated or whatever it's more
complicated than what people like you
and me think
so it seems to me that the following
things are true
first there will be lots of jobs but ai
will displace a lot of current jobs
think about a security guard
you know the security guard basically
sits around and watches all day well a
computer is better at that than the
security guard see if all the security
guard is doing is watching then that can
be replaced but if the security bar
guard is also your brand they're warm
and friendly and we love you and we
welcome you
to our to our home or to our business or
what have you well then that's a
function that maybe ai won't replace
so you're going to see people pushed
into more human roles
and there'll be lots of them
eventually
the scenario that everybody talks about
is going to be true
some number of decades maybe a hundred
years
the technology world will be so good
that we can grow food we can build
buildings cheaply literally everyone can
live like a millionaire today this is a
long time ago long after i'm dead it'll
probably be true
we don't know what people will do
but one thing i'm sure is that people
are not going to be painting
they're going to find meaning you know
in other words we may get rid of the
security guard role but people will come
up with more legal structures or they'll
come up with more medical structures or
something else
but to say that somehow innovation will
ultimately eliminate meaning and in jobs
is is not supported by history
so one one of the things that this
raises for me is is the question of a
civilization without children because
you mentioned kids before and and the
kid who makes friends with the teddy
bear who then becomes their best friend
and is essentially sentient incapable of
making decisions and interacting with
kids but i want to ask a different
question which is we are a very
adult-driven society a society that is
built around the needs and pleasures of
people who are capable of giving consent
we're not a society that's particularly
driven by people having kids or what
people should do
with those kids and it seems like the
the ai world is driving more in the
adult direction that that if we are
interacting online we're not interacting
physically that kids are a lot of work
right i have three of them under the age
of eight and and they are an awful lot
of work and you know it's not as much
work as is existing in a vr reality
where you can hang out with all of your
adult friends all day the west is
already experiencing a pretty
large-scale crisis of underpopulation
not overpopulation every single major
western country is now reproducing at
less than replacement rates and it seems
like you know the distractions that are
that are created by not only an ai world
but also by interactive beings that that
are capable of fulfilling your every
need right
that this could totally undercut the
future of human reproduction of of
raising healthy children it's dangerous
stuff
this is completely unappreciated and
you've nailed it
we need to have human growth that is the
number of people
my position is simple we need more
immigration we need more reproduction we
need more families we need larger
numbers of kids because that's wealth
the ultimate answer to your life
is the legacy that you leave in your
children and your grandchildren and so
forth and the extraordinary achievements
that they will
develop because of the training and the
fatherhood in your case that you were
providing
we we can't lose that it's so important
and i'm completely in agreement with you
that we're building systems that are
addictive for humans and by addiction i
mean addictive for adults we see this in
all sorts of ways
dating is later
marriage is later family formation is
later the number of children is smaller
it's true by the way in every developed
country and it's also true in china
so let's talk about the the threat of
china so you mentioned china in this
context china has been pouring money
into ai china obviously has been using
technology as a wedge in order to
build
connections with wide variety of nations
whether it is trying to offer 5g with
strings attached to countries that are
that are underdeveloped uh or whether it
is trying to you know through direct
foreign aid make alliances with
countries that have access to rare earth
minerals china's become much more
threatening on the geopolitical stage
but it's underappreciated what they're
doing in the technological space both in
terms of subsidizing technology and in
terms of stealing technology from the
west how do we deal with the threat of
china in the space how threatening is it
if china gains an advantage in the ai
space
well i was fortunate to be the chairman
of a commission that the congress set up
a bipartisan commission on national
security and artificial intelligence
and we concluded that the threat from
china is quite real that they are at the
moment over investing compared to the
united states they're producing more
phds um the quality of their work this
year is now to the point where it's on
par or better than the best papers that
we're producing so they have arrived and
they've arrived quickly and they're over
investing
the consequences of this could be very
very significant you mentioned huawei
and 5g but think about tick tock tick
tock uses a different artificial
intelligence algorithm
your teenagers are perfectly happy to
use it and i don't mind if the chinese
know where your teenagers are but i do
mind if they use that platform to begin
to affect the way we communicate with
each other and so there's every reason
to think about the ai world that we want
in front of us represents western values
that is the western values of democracy
and free speech and free debate and so
forth and so on which are certainly not
present on the chinese side
there are also all sorts of national
security issues
i want to be careful about your
statement about cold war because that's
a that's a way of representing a certain
thing china by the way has an economy
which on a purchasing power basis is
larger than america's now russia was
never anywhere near that
also if you look today after all this
discussion about china we have more
trade between china and the in the us
this month than we ever have
so we're not in a cold war we're in a
rivalry and the rivalry has huge stakes
in the rivalry imagine if
china becomes the dominant player in ai
semiconductors computer science
energy transportation face recognition
electronic commerce and other services
that's my whole world that's everything
in tech
trillions and trillions of dollars of
companies that are being formed today
are in danger if we don't invest
and our report basically said the
government needs to help with research
funding
the there's lots of hiring that has to
occur within the government we have to
build partnerships with like-minded
countries south korea japan european
countries and so forth we've got to take
this seriously we've gotten bipartisan
support of this because both sides are
concerned about this for different
reasons so we may be able to actually
affect change imagine if the
semiconductors that we use in our
conversation right now and that your
viewers are using today were made in
china and had chinese infiltration in
one form or another you wouldn't be
comfortable and i wouldn't be
comfortable you have to really think
about this from the standpoint of
national security and open
communications
so eric you mentioned they're not using
the language of cold war but instead
using the language of rivalry i think
that many of us in the west tend to
think of china in in terms of rivalry
because as you mentioned there is so
much trade with with china because we
are so integrated with their economy but
china is obviously pursuing a
mercantilist economic policy while we
are pursuing a much more free market
policy right which means do they see it
as a rivalry or do they see it as an
actual cold war
well what i'll tell you what the chinese
have said publicly i've not talked to
them privately because we haven't been
able to go to to china for two years
because of coven
what they say publicly is that the
history of china was it was this
enormous middle kingdom
and for various reasons involving the
open wars and so forth 150 years ago
they were embarrassed
they withdrew they were put under
pressure their their strength was
constrained by historic accidents
they've all been taught this and now
this new president president xi is not
that new anymore is basically using this
language to ins shall we say
inflame nationalism uh to build
confidence he gives speeches now which
say we will never ever be at the thumb
of these other oppressors that's the
language that they use this is foaming
for fomenting
enormous self-confidence
and that self-confidence is fine as long
as it stays in its region
the problem with the self-confidence on
either side is it can lead to a series
of strategic missteps
a series of over confident moves
dr kissinger who's a co-author with us
on our book talks a lot about the
potential that the current situation
feels a lot like the preamble to world
war one
where you had rapid industrialization
new technology old rivalries that got
stoked and then a series of errors
precipitated a horrendous war and i can
tell you having worked for the u.s
military for five years
in my in my 20 job when i was at google
a real conflict with china would be
so horrific it has to be avoided we have
to find ways to coexist with china even
if we don't like what they're doing and
they have to find ways to coexist with
the system we build even if they don't
like we're doing
having that distrust but a working
relationship is better than world
destruction
so how should technology companies deal
with china one of the big issues
obviously is that it seems to a lot of
folks including me that china has taken
advantage of our of our free open
markets in order to cheat i mean they've
stolen an enormous amount of western
technology it seems as though they
dictate terms to western corporations
western corporations want to do business
in china and china basically then forces
those western corporations to abide by
particular rules in order to even do
business there that obviously on a
public level
is it's most clear with regards to for
example the nba where you had a gm of
the houston rockets criticizing china
over hong kong and the nba came down
hard on the gm of houston rockets less
trying to close its markets to the to
the nba but you've seen this in the tech
sphere also when you're at google
obviously there was significant
controversy over google search results
and chinese censorship how should tech
companies be dealing with the fact that
china says if you want to play in our
pond you got to play by our rules well
indeed google left china in 2010 in a
very controversial move because google
did not want to be subject to the rules
that you just said
i hate to be blunt about this
but the fact of the matter is you have
the rise of another power of a similar
size that operates differently from the
way we do
we can complain all we want to about the
things that they do
but since we're not willing to bomb them
and we're not willing to attack them
the use of force to force our way is not
going to work
we're going to have to find ways and
incentives i'll give you an example the
trump administration
and a fellow the guy who did is a guy
named dan potnegger who's really really
smart
under under trump
figured out
that chinese semiconductor leadership is
really really important to to keep back
and our our recommendation in our report
is that we try to stay
two generations ahead of china in
semiconductors
so the trump administration for example
identified technology in a company
called asml um it's complicated but
basically it's extremely
small
lines that go into the wafers
and this particular company which is a
dutch company is the only source of that
and the trump administration basically
made it impossible for that hardware and
software to make it to china right
that's a good example of the kind of
move that we need to consider to make
sure
that strategically our model continues
to win
i understand the issue of the history
and openness and they have a different
system but it's sort of like okay what
do you want to do about it i think the
answer is
instead of complaining about them
there's lots to complain about why don't
we complain about ourselves and fix
ourselves and in particular why don't we
focus on
technology excellence platform
excellence doing the things we do best
the american system is different from
the chinese system the chinese system is
integrated essentially an autocracy they
have something called military civil
fusion there's no difference between the
military and
and businesses the universities are all
interlinked and funded by the government
the sum of all that is just a different
system
why don't we make our system stronger
our system is the union of the
government and universities and the
private sector i'll give you another
example
who made the best vaccines well here
again under trump
operation workspeed the government
guaranteed the products independent of
where they worked or not the
universities developed the technologies
and the businesses took huge risks and
made a gazillion dollars and saved us
that's the best of america they all work
together to solve a problem that's what
we should be doing so in a second i want
to ask you on a broader level about
isolation versus interconnectedness with
china and i also want to get into some
of the the issues as to who controls the
the ai world and and who's you know who
who exactly should we be trusting with
the developments of this technology
first let's talk about how you send your
mail now this holiday season the lines
of the post office gonna be super long
everybody's getting back out there you
gotta send some packages to friends and
family well what if you wanna do that
but you don't wanna go to the post
office well do what we do use stamps.com
stamps.com lets you compare rates print
labels and access exclusive discounts on
ups and usps services all year long it
just makes sense especially if your
business sends more mail-in packages
during the holidays here at dailywire
we've used stamps.com since 2017. no
more wasting our time whether you're
selling online or running an office or a
side hustle stamps.com can save you so
much time money and stress during the
holidays access all the post office and
ups shipping services you need without
taking the trip and get discounts you
can't find anywhere else like up to 40
off usps rates and 76 off ups going to
the post office instead of using
stamps.com it's kind of like taking the
stairs instead of the elevator i mean
you might get a little more exercise but
also would you really want to do it like
every single day just take the elevator
if you spend more than a few minutes a
week dealing with mail and shipping
stamps.com is a lifesaver you'll save a
lot of time and a lot of money this is
why you should be doing it save time and
money this holiday season with
stamps.com sign up with promo code
shapiro for a special offer that
includes a four week trial free postage
digital scale no long term commitments
or contracts head on over to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
page enter promo code shapiro okay so
let's talk about interconnectedness
versus isolation particularly in regards
to the tech world so you have these
enormous multinational corporations
transnational corporations places like
google
so you mentioned that google withdrew
from china in 2010 at the same time we
do want to have impact for western
companies in china so how exactly should
tech companies be playing that game how
how should they be developing
relationships inside china is that even
possible given the amount of
isolationism that and and autarky that
that the chinese regime is pursuing
i think it's unlikely that the large
tech companies will have a big role in
china
um tesla has just done a large
development in china and i'm sure that
the chinese will take advantage of that
incredible transfer of knowledge and it
will also help the chinese local
manufacturers
i think just how they operate
i think the most likely scenario is that
we're going to see information
technology in the west and then a
different kind of information technology
in china and its and the bri countries
who are its partners and the reason is
that it china and her partners
are pretty much unified in the way they
want people to express things the way
they want to deal with anonymity the
the way they want to deal with the messy
aspects of free speech and the internet
um whereas in the west we're pretty
committed to to dealing with it and
supporting it in some way
so if you look all of the interesting
tech companies that do anything online
are essentially blocked or limited in
china in one way
it's interesting by the way that that
apple has managed to create the
following interesting structure
uh
apple is regulated by the chinese and
they fight all day as to what goes on in
the app store so apple could withdraw
from china but they want their revenue
but on the other hand china is also the
manufacturing source for apple's
products which is of great value the
chinese and so they have an
uncomfortable relationship so the most
likely scenario is either no
relationship or an uncomfortable
relationship of the kind that i've
described with apple in google's case uh
various people have tried to re-enter in
various ways and they've not been
successful so far
so i want to move kind of back to the
domestic sphere and back to the west for
a second because a lot of what we're
talking about here as far as machine
learning and ai well we've seen sort of
the the frodo version of that in how we
deal with social media and that of
course has been incredibly messy you
mentioned early on uh russian
interference or attempted interference
in the 2016 election obviously from the
right side of the aisle there's a strong
belief that a lot of the tech companies
particularly including youtube google
facebook that these places yeah are
designing algorithms that that may not
be free with regard to transfer of
information that somebody is setting the
rules and there's a lot of distrust as
to who is setting the rules at these
companies generally speaking now i'm not
comfortable with the government setting
the rules because i think that the
government generally tends to be run by
political hacks who then do exactly what
benefits them but at the same time
there's a lot of disquiet and i think a
lot of it is justified as to who sets
the rules so when there's a hate speech
regulation on on google or if there's a
hate speech standard on youtube how do
you define terms like this and who
defines what is sort of the best public
square
when when you take that sort of disquiet
and you extend it to things as
all-encompassing as ai you can see why
people are freaked out
this is a good preamble to the general
point we make in our book
that the tools for manipulating
information and i mean that broadly for
good or bad are going to be very broadly
distributed
and so the software to do the kinds of
scenarios on any side that you described
will be open source and available to
pretty much any actor a company
an institution a liberal organization a
conservative organization and so forth
and that manipulation
is not so good for society
in the book what we say is that
eventually people will have their own
assistance
basically software that understands what
they are care about
and also
make sure the sources of manipulation of
them are honest in other words it says
i'm going to choose this article for you
and this other article is really false
and i'm really not going to choose it
for you unless you want me to it'll be
under your control it'll be the only way
that people deal with this extraordinary
explosion of what i'm going to just call
misinformation and disinformation it'll
come from governments it'll come from
our own government it'll come from
others it'll come from evil people and
well-meaning people
and that's a big change in human society
we were all all of us were grown up
thinking that you should just believe
whatever people told you and now a
better understanding is that people are
trying to manipulate you and you have to
find your own way of thinking through
this with respect to the bias question
there's no question that the majority of
the tech companies are in liberal states
and
and the majority of their employees
are um for example democratic supporters
and so forth and so on that's the thing
to some degree cultural there are ways
to address what you said
the most important thing is public
pressure to make sure you have balance
and calling for regulation is always a
problem because bringing in a regulator
on either side right
is highly likely to fix things in their
current way and prohibit innovation the
way we're going to compete with china is
by innovating ourselves ahead what i
want is innovation that's consistent
with our values which include open
discourse freedom of expression freedom
of thought freedom of seeking things
so eric one of the things that's come up
in this context
is the is the question of monopoly so
there have been a number of of political
actors who've suggested that companies
like google effectively are monopolies
because they control so much of the ad
revenue market or because they control
so much of the search market do you
think that google is a monopoly and if
so what should be done about that how
should we view the problem of monopoly
given that while there are a wide
variety of sources that are available on
google google does control for example
the ranking of search results
yeah the question
the ques the google question we've had
since i've been there which is more than
20 years
and the question goes okay would you
like someone else to decide how to do
ranking so ranking is a is an
algorithmic decision that computers make
humans don't make and my first month at
google somebody called up and said
you're biased and i said well the
computer makes the decision and they
said um no there must be a human making
decision and i sat down with the
engineers and i'm convinced that there
was no bias because the algorithm made
the decision
if you want to regulate the algorithm
then write down how you would like it to
be different what are the rules and
you'll find it's extremely difficult
the people who are calling for antitrust
often say
these big companies which includes the
fang i guess the we're going to call
them the mang
companies now because facebook became
meta
not sure quite if that's a good idea or
not but the key thing about the mang
stocks
is they're very large and very
integrated and see people say ah let's
break them up so elizabeth warren for
example said let's take the app store
and separate it from the iphone let's
take youtube and separate it from google
uh etc there's a list
the problem with these things is they
don't they don't actually
they make a smaller a small number of
companies
it's good for the shareholders to break
them up because the value in aggregate
will go up
right that's the bizarre thing it's good
for the shareholders
in some because the distributions
they'll get but the problem is it
doesn't actually address the problem
that people it just it just essentially
creates more
big players
you have to come up with a way
of
addressing the network effects in these
platforms and the good execution and i
haven't seen it i think we'd be better
off regulating
the worst aspects you can make a list i
can make a list
rather than breaking them up in other
words if there's a specific thing that
you don't like that facebook does apple
does or google
write it down right and try to figure
out a way to regulate it in such a way
that it's a fair regulation that's
better than trying to break all these
things up
so in a second i want to ask you about
how the algorithms do work because
obviously somebody built the algorithm
in the first place there have to be some
sort of inputs or maybe i'm wrong about
that so i'm going to ask you about that
in just one moment first let's talk
about buying jewelry for a loved one
this holiday season it's the holiday
season you know what that means you have
to figure out what to get for your loved
one your mom your girlfriend your wife
well you know the answer to this
gentleman and the answer is fine pearl
jewelry which is not going to break your
budget at the pearl source you get the
highest quality pearl jewelry up to 70
percent off retail prices why well
because pearl source cuts out the
middleman by eliminating those crazy
markups by jewelry stores and selling
directly to you the consumer you can
shop securely from the comfort of your
home at the pearl source you'll find the
largest selection of pearls available
anywhere every jewelry piece is custom
made specifically for you with global
supply chain problems and shipping
carriers expecting major delays of
delivery times as you get closer to the
holidays now is indeed the best time to
start shopping for the holiday season so
do not wait the perl source offers fast
and free two-day shipping on every order
with zero contact delivery everything
comes beautifully packaged in an elegant
jewelry box it's ready to be given as a
gift i know this because i've given my
wife stuff from the pearl source she
loves it it is spectacular and here's
the thing for a limited time listeners
to the ben shapiro show sunday special
can take 20 off your entire order don't
wait until it's too late to do that
holiday shopping head on over to
thepearlsource.com
thepearlsource.com enter promo code
bennett check out for 20 off your entire
order if you want to find pearl jewelry
at the best prices online go straight to
the source the pearl source the
pearlsource.com backslash ben enter
promo code ben at checkout all righty so
let's talk about the algorithms so we we
hear this a lot in in the tech world and
for those of us who aren't in the tech
world it's somewhat confusing so we'll
hear something like you know the
algorithm makes the decision and those
of us who are not in the tech world say
right but somebody wrote the algorithm
there have to be some sort of variables
that are that are used as the inputs and
so do the biases of the people who are
building the algorithms come out in how
the algorithm actually operates so for
example if the algorithm suggests that
that certain types of speech are less
favored than others or certain types of
speech which are more favored by more
people because they are put out by the
legacy media are quote unquote more
trustworthy than other sources is that a
problem with the algorithm or is that a
problem with the inputs or how does that
get separated i don't want to claim that
these algorithms are perfect but i can
tell you how they're really built
you've got teams of tens of people
hundreds of people and they write an
awful lot of code and they test it and
they test it and test it
and their success
is based on some objective function
like a quality score or a click-through
rate now let me give you the extreme
version
a company social media company only
focuses on revenue
to get revenue you need as much
engagement as possible
how do you get the most engagement you
get as much outrage as possible you get
addicted to the outrage and you can't
get rid of this and the money goes up
and up and up and up
that's the natural outcome of these
social networks if you want to maximize
revenue hopefully the leaders of these
companies are trying to do other things
that just maximizing revenue
but it's a good example where the
algorithm
which is or in using this fictional
example all it wants is more money
so all it's going to do is get more
attention and drive you insane
right i don't know how you regulate that
but that's an example of a company that
would be very good for its shareholders
but a bad company to be part of
how do we bridge the gap between i think
there have been a few semantic games
that have happened over the course of
the last several years it's really kind
of fascinating to see how the media
treatment of big tech companies and
social media companies changed radically
in the aftermath of 2016. so in 2012
there was wide praise for the social
media companies how they had affected
change in for example the arab spring or
how they connected people during the
original black lives matter movement or
how they had connected people during the
2012 campaign and by 2016 after trump
won there seemed to be a pretty radical
shift in how the media started treating
social media suddenly social media was
the bugaboo social media had opened the
door too broadly it had allowed too much
disinformation and the question of
disinformation which is effective
there's a definition to that term right
this information being an an opposing
state actor or or
some sort of entity that is antithetical
to to the interests of the united states
actively putting out information that is
wrong in order to undermine the
institutions that's disinformation then
there's a shift semantically from
disinformation to misinformation
misinformation meaning either something
that i think is false or something that
is actively false and and all these
lines started to get blurred this is
where as a conservative i start to get
very wary is is the the notion that
there is some sort of great gatekeeper
that there can be a gatekeeper function
performed by an algorithm that goes
beyond simply saying we're not going to
allow articles to be disseminated that
say two plus two equals five instead we
are going to go to an outside group of
for example fact checkers who may be
biased in their own right and then use
an aggregate score which looks objective
but actually isn't because the inputs
are not objective and one of the things
that that i think many of us on the
right are pushing for is less regulation
specifically because we want more speech
on these platforms not less speech
that's why i think that it's very odd to
see the common cause being made between
some on the left who want the speech
heavily regulated on these platforms and
some people on the right who want the
platforms broken up what is the what
what's the best way to open up these
platforms if you are for example a
startup right my company was a startup
we started this company in 2015. this
company was launched on the back of the
power of social media and then pretty
much every day we have to fight in in
the press and we have to fight social
media you know algorithms that are
attempting to upgrade for example the
new york times and maybe downgrade sites
like ours because we aren't quite as
established
what you're describing is the current
world that we did not anticipate 10
years ago
the fantasy that we all had was that we
would see an enormous explosion in
speech and we would see a great deal of
decentralized actors
a very very large number of small
players who would collectively be very
interesting because i agree with you
that we need more speech we need more
speech from everyone and we also by the
way need more listening to everyone
and instead what we've ended up with is
a concentration of essentially large
vertical sites which have some of the
aspects that you're describing what's
the answer
i hope it's not government regulation i
agree with you
i hope the answer is more competitors
so what it will it take to get
competitors to all of these players an
example is that a former google
executive has left to create a
competitor to google
which is run very differently we'll see
how well it does
my view that's a welcome thing
we need competition for example for
facebook and the way it operates we need
different ways of experiencing ourselves
um in a situation where the president
was the former president was banned by
twitter and facebook he needs a
competitor who will host him and will
give him an audience so that his voice
can be heard right that makes sense to
me
uh on those terms
now the problem you have so let's assume
we have all of that let's assume the
answer is more speech and more good
speech
there doesn't seem to be a penalty for
lying anymore there doesn't seem to be a
penalty for absolute factual falsehoods
and especially in the case of
the code situation where they affect
lives we've got to come up with one some
solution which is not an overlord and
not a regulator but which basically
causes people to believe that we should
focus on facts and not fiction and we
haven't figured that out yet at google
and google is not perfect we face this
question and google is full of
falsehoods
but we have a ranking algorithm and
hopefully the falsehoods are lower than
the non-falsehoods
and when we were building google what we
did is we would do trade-offs between
revenue and quality
and i arbitrarily decided that whenever
we had an improvement half of it would
go to quality and half of it would go to
revenue because i couldn't decide
between the two
so that's an example of informed
decision that in my view helped the
company become the high gold standard of
answers but it's not perfect
we need equivalent conversations but i
mean let me tell you that if you're in
the business
of peddling falsehoods
which you better not but if you are in
that
and you're peddling falsehood then
there's no check on you
shame on you right get your facts right
and i'm not talking about theories and
so forth i'm talking about basic facts
do your research what i've learned as a
citizen
is when people make claims did you know
this and did you know that people say
all sorts of things you know i check
i check because i don't want to be
misinformed by my friend
let alone by any form of media and i
would encourage people you need to be
your own best advocate for truth and
do your own research don't just believe
what people tell you
and so eric in the covered context it's
actually a really interesting context to
talk about this because you're right
that there there is a category of
disinformation from particular states
actually uh and and certainly
misinformation and actual untruths that
were put out with regard to covet uh
ranging from the origins of covid
perhaps to the to the effectiveness of
the vaccines which are in fact highly
effective against hospitalization and
death although not nearly as effective
against infection or reinfection um but
one of the things that they came up in
this context and it really does go to
human nature and this may go to the
broader conversation about ai is that
because the
data were constantly moving because it
was just there wasn't a lot of data
about covered at the beginning it was it
was a brand new virus and because that
data was being gathered there was a lot
of shifting that happened by the
institutional players in the society we
we had anthony fauci for example
claiming at the beginning that people
should not wear masks and then admit
that he was telling a platonic lie and
probably should wear a mask and then we
were told after after the vaccines were
available that you shouldn't mask and
then after delta came up then it was you
should wear a mask again uh and
this has happened across the board and
sort of shifting and moving by the
institutions itself
mirrored by the tech companies which
basically said the institutions are the
best available source of information
therefore if you contradict them we're
going to downgrade your information
it actually drove i think part of the
backlash to the actual truth in a lot of
these cases i think it drove a lot of
anti-vac sentiment that the tech
companies seem to be quote-unquote
silencing
other forms of of of argumentation even
if the even if they were right to
silence particular particular notions
about you know completely unfactual
ideas about covet
we've been through a pandemic that
occurs hopefully less than every
every 100 years
or so more than one every 100 years very
rare
and there were lots of mistakes made at
the beginning including the ones you
described and many others in my view
there was a point sometime last summer
where the facts became clear that the
vaccines would work and god god save us
it really worked and people are alive
today
it's also true that masks work
it's also true that public health
matters it's also true that you as a
covid if you have covid
um you're most infectious the two days
before you have symptoms
so to say that i'm just going to have my
own covet and have a good time which is
in my view a perfectly fine speaking as
a sort of libertarian view perfectly
fine it's not it's okay for you to do
that it's not okay for you to do that
for other people that's where the
narrative got confused
my issue now is we are now at a point
where the science is well established
i think it's not okay for people to
propagate falsehoods that involve
population health and people's lives
i just honestly don't think it's okay
and that's independent of whether the
democrats made a mistake or the
republicans made a mistake where there's
plenty of blame to go around
i've been advocating by the way for a
private commission
to go and actually analyze all this it
would have to be bipartisan everything
that i've done in the commission space
has been bipartisan and it's worked well
you can bridge across the aisle around
important things for our society we are
all americans right we somehow we forget
in the fight that we are americans that
we have the same culture and the same
values we've got to figure out solutions
i will tell you that
this the ease with which people can
market falsehoods because of the new
tools and i'm not taking sides on this
it's dangerous
because a lot of people are just trying
to get through the day they just want
someone to help them understand what's
going on they don't want to become their
own experts on everything they're they
have lives and busy and so forth they
want to watch tv or whatever it is we
need to help them and make sure they're
not inundated with falsehoods okay so so
eric you're talking about you know the
informational question and and sort of
what should be allowed and what
shouldn't and i agree with you there's
definitely brightline issues right if
you say that n95 is completely
ineffective that's obviously a lie it's
obviously not true if you want to say
that the federal government of the
united states unleashed this on people
just in order to kill them and take
control that obviously is untrue and
there are a lot of patent untruths out
there but but one of the questions that
i think is is going to crop up as we
mentioned more and more often as ai
becomes more and more a part of our
lives is who gets to make the call as to
what is a bright line lie and what is
just stuff that is sort of controversial
and there are edge cases and and my fear
is that the edge cases start to
bleed over into more mainstream points
of view the overton window starts to
shrink because we've seen that happen in
nearly every area of american public
speech that the overton window has
shrunk pretty radically and when that
happens there are two dangers one is
that actual innovative ideas and and
questions get left out and the other is
that eventually it breeds a massive
backlash when you wish enough people out
enough perspectives out into the
cornfield they tend to unify and then
attack the center
we need to get back to the way the world
at least that i grew up in where
speech was considered okay if it was
controversial but it was also debated
and it was not done in a screaming way i
think it's incredibly important that our
universities reflect all the points of
view and that they welcome them and that
there be public debate over it i think
it's fine for people to make these kinds
of claims i just don't want the
computers to then sell them
one way to understand my view is to say
i'm really
a strong believer in adult public speech
free speech
i'm not in the in favor of the
equivalent speech for for computers
in other words the fact that you're a
crazy person i'm sorry to say this a
crazy person um who has a crazy idea
that's fine
but it's not okay in my view that your
crazy idea then becomes magnified to the
point where it becomes a dominant theme
when it's just frankly something that
you made up
we haven't figured out as a society how
to address this thing the tools that
were debated that we're developing are
addictive
the addiction
is driven to some degree by narrative
and the more exciting the narrative and
by the way the more disruptive and the
more aggressive the narrative the more
clicks the more revenue the more success
the more fame we've got to find a
balance there if you look at history
when the printing press came out of the
original broad sheets and so forth were
regulated advertising was regulated
because it got out of control it began
to affect the society we're now about to
make everyone be a publisher and
everyone be a potential misinformer
we've got to sort that out in our book
what we say
is that this affects the way people will
believe that they're human right i was
in a
a lunch restaurant
in florida recently and i was looking at
everybody and everyone at the table this
is at lunch was on their phones
right rather than looking at each other
and interacting maybe they were bored
with each other i don't know right these
that's how addictive these tools are the
ai system is going to get so good that
it'll be able to generate addiction for
you that's so precise that you'll be so
consumed by it and why do i know this
because it's reproducible we can we
collectively as the tech industry can
see what you care about and we can give
you more and more and more and more
and frankly that's a pretty good life oh
my god another one oh my god another one
it's in when i was growing up we had
music with you know records where the
songs were in order it was track four
and track eight
now your playlists are
you know assembled for you by computers
well a world where the playlist of your
life and your information is assembled
for you
it's pretty powerful to be the group
that's assembling that
and what if they for example promulgate
values we don't agree with like racism
or sexism or doing bad things to
children or things like that how do we
want to handle that i'm not asking for
more regulation but i'm asking for some
judgment here
on the use of these tools
yeah eric it seems to me that a lot of
what we're talking about here is only
going to be solved in the offline world
so we're constantly looking for you know
solutions to the problem because the
problem exists in the online world or in
the social media space but i mean as
i've found you know it's the ability to
actually see and speak to one another as
human beings that's really important and
as ai becomes much more powerful as we
spend more and more time online society
seems to be getting significantly worse
it's a lot easier to treat people badly
anonymously than it is in person and
simultaneously the deepest connections
are the ones that can be found in person
it's there's a great irony to the fact
that that all of these tools that were
supposed to bring people together have
sort of flattened our existence in in a
pretty significant way and there is
something innate to the to the human
human connection that is necessary in
order to build actual social capital and
as we spend more time online which was
supposed to generate social capital is
it building more social capital or is it
just fragmenting us more by flattening
us well the good news is the bowling
alone theory which is 20 years ago was
false right the bowling alone theory was
that we would all be sitting isolated
watching television at home
in fact if you look at our young people
they spend literally every minute online
of their waking day their phones are
next to their bed if they wake up in the
middle of the night they get on their
phone if they get up in the morning the
first thing they check is their phone so
we already know the answer where is your
teenager your teenager is online on
their phone
we also know where your adult friends
are we also know where your kids are we
also know where your your parents are
they're all online so we've answered
that question the question is what kind
of a world we do we want
i used to say uh 10 years ago
that this world was optional
that if you don't like it just turn it
off it's okay no problem i don't mind i
think it's good to take a break you
can't take a break from it anymore it's
become the way you educate the way you
entertain the way you make money right
the way you communicate the way you have
a social life so we're going to have to
adapt these platforms to these human
regulations i used to think it's fine to
have all that bad stuff online because
people can just turn it off but they
can't now we're gonna and what you're
gonna see
whether we like it or not is if the tech
companies don't figure out a way to
organize this in such a way they will
get regulated on this and the initial
regulator will be europe and by the way
in case we're confused on this china has
solved this problem china does not allow
anonymous browsing
furthermore you so you're logged in they
know who you are and they have tens of
thousands of people who watch for
forbidden speech they have very
sophisticated ai algorithms that watch
for what people say and then the police
come lock come knocking we don't want
that i mean i do wonder you know as a
religious jew one of the big things for
us and it seems to be more and more
relevant every day is the sabbath right
this this enforced mandatory get offline
kind of circuit breaker that exists
every friday night to every saturday
night and it really does i think ground
you in a certain reality on a social
level i'm not talking about legislation
here on a social level it seems to me
that it's going to be very important
that human beings do find a way to
disconnect from this technology at least
for a little while and and start to to
re-ground themselves in a material
reality that exists offline i agree with
that um i worked in in utah for a while
and in utah the
lds mormons have a similar procedure
involving evenings where they're
connected only to their family because
their families are so important
i went with governor bill richardson to
north korea a few years ago and one of
the things we did is we left our phones
before we went to north korea because
obviously you couldn't use them
and for three days we had
an experience that i've not had in
decades we talked to each other we got
to know each other the traveling group
we we enjoyed our trip the moment we got
back out of north korea we're online
we're back at it
it was as though we didn't learn
anything
from our three days offline and we went
right back that's how powerfully
addictive these technologies are so in a
second i do want to ask you a couple of
more questions but if you want to hear
eric schmidt's answers and these are
going to be deep questions then first
you have to head on over to dailywire
and become a member go to dailywire.com
click subscribe you can hear the rest of
our conversation over there
well eric schmidt it's been a pleasure
having you here the book again is the
age of ai and our human future go check
it out it's available for purchase right
now eric thanks so much for joining the
show really appreciate it thank you ben
as always and i'll see you
[Music]
the soon shapiro show sunday's special
is produced by mathis glover executive
producer jeremy boring and our assistant
director is pavel wydowsky our guests
are booked by caitlin maynard editing is
by jim nicholl audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
cristina title graphics are by cynthia
angulo the ben shapiro show sunday
special is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
[Music]